it's pretty pretty London you don't even
know if you were savory
okay you know what's going on you know
any reason why no any reason why you
don't know what's happening you know
what's happening in Libya probably not
everything I need to do you know why
these people are here today to do with
lives matter I didn't know this is
anything under Libya to be you need to
know you think what's happening here is
the frustration that this is not being
talked about that's why these people
have to come to the streets and block
traffic
yeah it's going to change it if we blame
them I don't blame any ones right for
peaceful process yeah hi sir do you have
any idea what's going on I'm you got a
credit card no there's black film that's
been enslaved and being sold like there
that there's some kind of an item
imagine if there was white people being
sold as slaves do you think you would
have known about it more possibly yeah I
can say why yeah it's no it's not great
white people were being sold as slaves
you would have heard about it
or in the media just for what I wanna do
he was wife you mean solar slaves yeah
would you would it wouldn't it be all
over the media this is it butyl racism
is dying or still alive still alive
still alive this time we'll kill it
yeah yeah without internet obviously so
do you think racism is dying or is still
alive
racism is is always there but I think
it's getting better but we need more to
do just against slavery in Libya have
you heard about what's going on there
before my but that's in Libya we are
here we're allowing you know have a
people to come into this country and to
demonstrate in a good way this is not a
good way you won't get anybody support
we use in this traffic like this for you
know about this if you go back into the
days the Irish were sold with slaves
no one was an uproar about them that's
why you get so aren't many Irish
Jamaicans Reisman doesn't surprise you
why not oppose the horrible things
happen as well
why people being so the sold as slaves
in the market do you think social media
TV don't be a mass appeal people wake up
but when it's Africa when it's people
color where these people have melon ated
descent they don't want to listen so you
know we have to come in this fashion so
people listen you not me because
obviously any save against anybody is is
a humanitarian is a manatorian folk yeah
let alone African see time and time
again people are color marinated
whatever we see it time and time again
it's about time it stop staring at me do
you think racism is dying but it still a
line and it just evolved it just changed
you know I mean you'll always be for
this for this economy for this kind of
work for the Western world to survive
they need that that's why they thrive on
you yeah yeah divided on ruling taking
everyone's resources gonna have the
resources of their own has Parliament
built upon a flood no slavery no
Parliament is pretty pretty London you
even know hello aunty Hayden who's white
people being soaked in auctions do you
think the media would have covered it
more very much why do we have that
problem well there's racism isn't there
African people don't have a view they're
not people they're animals they've been
sold before and they will continue to
sell us and we're saying no more slavery
absolutely out of order absolutely out
of order no we're coming with joining
our gate gentlemen that's it exactly if
you with us you're with us if you're
black you're black if you're with us
you're with us we're here that's it
pause coming together coming together at
the end of day is warm mutual game it's
one game slam alaikum brother systems
hope you guys are well what guys doing
well as you can see right behind me is
the protest is most likely I think the
third or the fourth protest now I was
going to cover this issue right from the
beginning but I didn't want you you know
why because I didn't want to sit down at
home do a face to come video all
brothers and sisters what's going on in
Libya blah blah blah you know no no we
had to do something more powerful and
come here
behind as you can see behind me and let
you guys see the impact and the the
level that is reached now these people
out here they've come here a finger
slider four o'clock and this is the
third March yet and they've been
blocking the roads and rightly so
because you need to understand something
Brahman sisters here we don't want this
issue to be like a trend you know that
RINs go around I'm a youtuber yeah this
trend goes on Palestine minutes out yes
let's all jump on board Palestine
Palestine free free Palestine
what is Velma beam attack yeah everybody
jump from board it becomes like a trend
where it's like as a youtuber as a
public figure we need to come and say
yeah I talked about Burma yeah I talked
about Palestine yeah if I'm I talked
about Libya no no it's not and one thing
that we need to understand that there is
racism that still exists within our
communities we have to speak the truth
Allah says in the Quran talk the truth
even if it's against yourself within our
Muslim communities there is still racism
there is I'm sorry I spent many videos
before but today as you can see in Libya
10 Libya and these individuals be they
Muslim or non-muslim taking people human
beings human beings yeah I've seen
videos where I'm gonna show you some
images where you can see for yourself
disgusting they're treating them like
animals and they're selling them like
they're flipping flipping candy or
something so you can see both the
sisters that this act is disgusting and
as human beings Allah said honest verses
in the Quran which crazy tribes and
nations so you can get to know one
another to say so that's why I came in
today you know why because I know knows
can happen after a month after two weeks
after one week after two three months is
gonna be forgotten that's it
something we're gonna come here and it
shouldn't be like that when there is a
problem that's happening we should
address it head-on
as a Muslim my community my job is to to
raise awareness there's two reasons
number one is my duty to view it number
two it's like I said to you before we
still have the disease of racism the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him in
his last film and said a black is mostly
put over a wife neither a white super
over a black neither is Arab superior
over non Arab and neither none are over
Arab and I'm sorry to say it
Arabs be it Muslim or non-muslim there
is this huge complex
I'm better than him because he's black
where'd you get this from and I'm here
to say this as a Muslim
slam is free from this behavior Islam is
free from racism and treating other
people like violent animals that's why
we're here today and you saw we went and
talked to people out on the street taxi
drivers have you heard about Olivia no
no no no what happened why I haven't
heard of Olivia if it was why people be
insult I'm telling you they would have
flipped this earth upside down probably
so black people when it's Muslims when
it's whatever whatever whatever they
don't want to know
if I'm not mistaken there's a petition
going on or there's they're raising
money for this donate in the link below
and shala and do your part and raise
awareness and raise awareness as Muslims
we should be at the forefront fighting
this issue I squash it wife why way if
it was white people being enslaved
excuse me madam excuse me madam madam
madam if it was wife you were being
enslaved would you say the same thing me
why should they be ashamed of their self
if it was your people why people being
enslaved would you say the same thing
yeah I think your silence speaks loud
words thank you very much
CNN Yahoo CNN yeah have you cover
covered what's been going on in Libya
we're the ones that did it
we did the storm is it really we want to
cover the auction well ask you a
question why you're not aware of this
thanks Romania doesn't like wideout wife
it was no offense here what if it was
someone that looked like you being sold
as slave yeah in markets me everywhere
why what does that tell us
I'm here with
ow
my car
this time
I'm one of those are these gonna come up
with this wedding video